So here are our three answers. We have p inverse of x equals x plus 1, q
inverse of x equals one fourth times x minus 9, and r inverse of x equals x
cubed. I've done the work in the same way as last time including the color
change, when we switch from the original function to the inverse function. And
what's really important to notice about this quiz is that the equations we end
up with in the end. As the inverses of these functions, are the equations we
stared out with in the quiz before this one. We started with f of x equals x
plus 1, and found that it's inverse was f inverse of x equals x minus 1. We
ended up with this, 4x plus 9, by taking the inverse of a function that was
equal to this one. And the same is true of this equation. I'd like you to mull
this over and keep it in mind.